the way Andrew Tate made his money was
pure genius he had a course called
Hustler's University for 50 a month
which taught people different ways to
make money and one of those ways was
affiliate marketing where you earn a
commission for promoting someone else's
product he would then teach you to
promote Hustler's University where you
would get 25 for every sale you got from
the course but that wasn't the special
part then he provided you with all the
clips of him saying the most insane
stuff that were guaranteed to go viral
on Tick Tock then he taught you how to
edit those clips into tick tocks what
captures and all and it worked some
Affiliates made eleven thousand dollars
in a week while Tate made around 60
million dollars sadly Tay had to shut
this down but luckily we just launched
our own affiliate program just like this
but instead of a measly 25 commission
you get four times that at around a
hundred dollars and yes we also give you
all the resources that they gave to his
Affiliates check it out with the link in
the pin comment